Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Je sais ce que vous vous dites.
Qu’est-ce que c’est que ça ?
(Rires)
Je vois toutes les filles de la salle
ce soir me regarder en se disant :
« Oh oh oh la la !
Qu’est-ce qu’il a
de beaux cheveux, celui-là ! »
(Rires)
Je sais, c’est l’effet
que je fais aux femmes.
À défaut de leur plaire, je les rends
jalouses avec mes cheveux.
(Rires)
Ça rigole bien trop
de ce côté-là à cette blague.
(Rit)
J’ai un rapport assez particulier
aux femmes à vrai dire.
Les autres hommes, par rapport aux femmes,
ils dégagent de la testostérone,
moi, par rapport aux femmes,
je dégage... tout court.
(Rires)
« Va-t’en loin de moi, s’il te plaît. »
Mais ce que vous ne savez pas,
c’est que derrière, il y a un coiffeur.
Mais moi, je n’ai pas besoin de lui.
Moi capillairement,
je suis une expérience.
Quand il m’a vu entrer, il s’est dit :
« Qu’est-ce qu’il nous fait celui-là ?
Mais pour qui tu te prends ? »
Je profite, je suis jeune, j’ai 20 ans,
je profite d’avoir des cheveux.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Je profite parce que je sais que l’âge
et l’heure à laquelle je vais les perdre
arrivent à grands pas.
Je vois la ligne là reculer
peu à peu, tous les jours.
Ça me fait peur.
C'est comme ça.
Je vieillis, je grandis.
Je le sais : on me propose
de nouvelles choses.
Rien que là, TEDx, on m’a proposé ça,
j’étais déboussolé.
Je savais ce que c'était que les TEDx.
C’est le truc pour les vieux.
La dernière fois que j’ai parlé
devant des adultes,
c’était en quatrième pour faire
un exposé sur François Ier, tu vois.
Entre-temps, j’ai passé le bac,
mais ce n’est pas pareil.
Plein de nouvelles choses qui remodèlent
ma vie et qui apportent du changement.
Dernièrement, mesdames, messieurs,
j’ai emménagé dans mon propre appart.
(Applaudissements)
Merci, merci, merci beaucoup.
Gros changement dans une vie
d’emménager pour la 1e fois.
J’ai décidé de quitter mon ancien domicile
car la maison était habitée par un démon
qui s’appelle mon père.
Donc j'ai décidé de prendre mon envol.
Donc j’ai fait tout ce truc-là,
déménager, emménager,
et une fois bien installé chez moi,
j’ai dû faire ce truc
que je trouve totalement débile,
mais que tout le monde fait.
À chaque fois que quelqu’un venait
chez moi pour la première fois,
je devais lui faire visiter mon appart.
Ouais, ça, c’est un truc...
Vous le faites aussi ?
Ben oui, tout le monde le fait, tout le
monde le fait, mais ça ne sert à rien.
Ce moment, quand tu vas
en soirée chez un pote,
la 1e fois que tu vas chez lui,
le mec te fait visiter sa maison.
On dirait Louis XIV à Versailles.
« Voilà, ça c’est mon salon,
avec mon canapé, il est merveilleux. »
Mais arrête, mec ! Arrête !
Dis-moi juste où est-ce que je mange,
où est-ce que je dors, que je bois.
C’est tout.
Je n’ai pas besoin de savoir
les revêtements de tes murs et tout.
Non, surtout que c’est super malsain.
Le mec te fait pénétrer l’intimité
des gens de sa famille.
Il arrive comme ça, ouvre une porte :
« Voilà, ça, c’est
la chambre de mes parents.
C’est là où ils m’ont fait.
(Rires)
Mon père avait pris une douche,
mis du Barry White, quelques bougies.
C’était génial. »
C’est horrible. Et ce n’est pas fini.
Après, il traverse un couloir,
ouvre une deuxième porte :
« Voilà, ça, c’est la chambre
de ma petite sœur. »
Qu’est-ce que tu racontes ? Elle a 15 ans,
il y a un nounours sur son lit.
Qu’est-ce que tu me fais là ?
C’est super glauque, arrête !
En vrai, je comprends ces trucs-là,
parce que moi,
je suis super fier de mon appart.
Je suis super fier de mon appart parce
que j’ai emménagé avec mon grand frère.
On fait une colocation et on a chacun
sa chambre et chacun sa salle de bains.
Depuis que j’ai ma salle de bains à moi,
je fais des trucs de fou :
je m’accroche au pommeau, je fais
le poirier dans le carré de douche,
je me lave des endroits que
je ne m’étais jamais lavés auparavant.
Je me lave les jambes moi-même.
Je n’attends pas
que le savon coule sur moi.
L’arrière des genoux,
ça, je peux vous le dire,
ça n’avait pas vu le savon depuis 2007.
Mais il y a pire que ça.
Il y a carrément des gens
qui viennent chez toi
et qui te demandent à toi
de leur faire visiter à eux.
« Tu me fais visiter ? » C’est quoi,
cette phrase ? Tu me prends pour qui ?
Tu me prends pour un guide
touristique ou quoi ?
Tu n’es pas capable de reconnaître
les pièces d’une maison ?
Tu vois bien que là,
s’il y a une gazinière,
c’est probablement la cuisine.
Mais le mieux quand tu emménages,
les amis, le mieux,
c’est quand tu reçois tes parents
chez toi pour la première fois,
parce que là, tu fais ce que tu veux.
Ta maison, tes règles.
Ah oui ! Je peux vous le dire,
Je leur ai ressorti toutes les phrases
qui m’énervaient quand j’étais gosse.
Sans pression.
Mon père en plus, il a un délire.
Vous allez très vite comprendre
pourquoi je suis parti.
Il faut dire les choses.
Quand on mange,
on doit porter un tee-shirt.
Même si on est dehors,
il est 13 h,
on est en plein été,
il fait 40 degrés.
Non, tu mets un tee-shirt.
Les amis, la première fois que
mon père est venu manger chez moi,
c’était un soir en plein hiver.
La 1e chose que j’ai faite, je l’ai
regardé et j’ai enlevé mon tee-shirt.
Je l’ai regardé droit
dans les yeux, le Bernard.
(Rires)
Je l’ai regardé, je mangeais
comme ça mon repas.
J'avais froid, j'avais froid de ouf.
Mais j’étais heureux !
(Rires)
Oh là là !
Et j’ai vu dans ses yeux, tu sais, le...
Ça, les amis,
c’est la définition du bonheur.
(Rires)
Je vous le dis.
Mais bon, vous le savez, qui dit nouvelle
vie dit aussi nouvelles responsabilités.
Par exemple, comme je vous le disais,
je fais une coloc avec mon grand frère.
C’est-à-dire, en gros, on fait 50-50.
C’est-à-dire que lui paye le loyer ;
moi, j’habite les lieux.
(Rires)
Non, en vrai, je paie le loyer,
mais ça par exemple,
c’est une préoccupation
que tu n’as pas quand tu es gosse.
Quand tu as douze ans,
le loyer, tu t’en fous.
Tu sais vaguement ce que c’est, tu sais
que c’est quelqu’un qu’on n’aime pas trop,
mais ça s’arrête là.
Toi, ton problème c’est si tu vas avoir
des biscuits le matin au petit déj.
Sauf que le souci,
c’est que, moi, j’ai 20 ans,
j’ai un appart,
et mon problème,
c’est si je vais avoir mes biscuits
le matin au petit dej.
C’est-à-dire que mon frère, il a 26 ans,
il a un gosse de 20 ans ; c’est chaud !
Comme je le disais, des fois,
ces responsabilités arrivent dans ta vie,
elles te mettent une petite claque,
et ça fait très très peur.
Par exemple, dernièrement,
je rentre chez moi.
Sur mon bureau, en train de m’attendre :
une lettre des services fiscaux.
Ouf !
Mauvaise ambiance !
Oh non, non, non !
Ah, ça fait peur !
Quand tu as 20 ans, tu rentres chez toi,
une lettre des services fiscaux,
tu te dis : « Ça y est, c’est fini.
Fin du jeu ! »
Tu es là, tu t’imagines déjà
en tenue orange, derrière les barreaux.
Sortir ! Trouve porte.
On ne peut pas sortir -
mais j’aime bien le mime quand même
(Rires)
Tu vois, tu t’imagines déjà comme ça
croupir jusqu’à la fin de ta vie
dans la folie la plus totale,
avec quatre mecs
qui te regardent avec envie,
avec la seule envie de te faire la peau.
Tu t’imagines déjà mourir comme ça
dans ton pipi, ton caca et ton vomi,
avec les matons
qui passent et qui te disent :
« Ha ha ha ! Bien fait pour toi !
Fallait payer tes impôts ! »
(Applaudissements)
C’est un peu trop ?
En même temps, ça fait flipper.
Tu te dis « Ça y est,
ma seule issue, c’est la mort. »
Oui, parce qu'en même temps, regardez,
depuis qu'on est petit, on va à l'école.
Enfin normalement, pour tout le monde.
Après, tu vas au collège.
Pendant 4 ans, on te prépare
à passer le brevet, tu as le brevet blanc.
Après, tu vas au lycée pendant 3 ans
pour préparer le bac, t’as le bac blanc,
Il n’y a pas de redressement fiscal blanc.
(Rires)
Il n’y a pas de mise en demeure blanc.
Non, jamais tu ne reçois
un petit courrier qui te dit :
« Vous devez 300 000 francs au fisc,
mais t’inquiète,
(Rires)
c’est 300 000 francs blancs. »
Non, là, il faut payer maintenant.
Pas de négociation.
Jamais il n’y a quelqu’un
qui t’appelle à 22h30 pour te dire :
« Allo, bonsoir.
Votre grand-mère est décédée, mais...
c’est tranquille. »
Non, non, non, là c’est :
« Allo ? Mamy est morte. »
Pan !
Ça tire à balles réelles, d’accord ?
Tu es lâché dans la jungle ;
plus de jeu, d’accord ?
Là, c’est la vraie vie qui commence.
Maintenant ! Il faut être préparé.
Donc j’ai ouvert cette lettre, les amis.
Et j’ai dû faire...
une déclaration de revenus.
Qu’est-ce que c’est que ça ?
Vous, vous rigolez, parce que...
Vous, ça fait longtemps
que vous êtes dans le game.
Moi, je viens juste
de rentrer dans la fête.
Je ne connais pas les règles du jeu.
La déclaration de revenus,
j’ai eu un problème avec.
Je vais vous expliquer pourquoi.
À un moment, effectivement,
j’ai eu de l’argent.
Pas beaucoup, hein, juste assez
pour qu’on me le prenne.
Et cet argent, il est parti.
Il est parti à une vitesse fulgurante.
Parce que ça, notez-le - les jeunes
dans la salle ce soir, notez-le -
l’argent que tu as part toujours.
L’argent n’est pas fidèle.
L'argent ne reste pas.
Sauf que, moi, on me demande
une déclaration de revenus.
Mais mon argent, il est parti.
Il n’est jamais revenu.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Je ne peux pas techniquement te -
Je peux te faire une déclaration de
« parti » ou une déclaration de « venu »,
mais pas de « revenu ».
(Rires)
Ça, notez-le, c’est très important aussi :
l’argent qui part ne revient pas.
Ça ne revient jamais, l’argent,
c’est dans un seul sens.
Je vais vous expliquer en plus
dans quoi il est parti.
Bien évidemment, j’en ai profité
pour faire de nouvelles choses.
Dernièrement, mesdames, messieurs,
je me suis inscrit en salle de sport.
Le premier qui rigole, je vais être véner.
(Rires)
Je me suis inscrit en salle de sport
pour des raisons évidentes
de crédibilité et de sécurité.
(Rires)
Hé hé !
Parce que je sais très bien
qu’avec le corps que j’ai,
je n’inspire ni le respect ni la peur,
et qu’en cas de possible agression,
ma seule défense, c’est la fuite.
La fuite accompagnée du cri.
(Rires)
et je crois que ça se voit sur mon corps,
la fuite, ce n’est pas mon fort.
Courir, même ça, je ne sais pas faire.
J’en avais marre d’être une victime,
je suis allé m’inscrire en salle de sport.
Je rentre dans la salle,
je vois en face de moi le coach sportif.
Les amis, le coach sportif,
ce n’est pas genre « il est beau »,
non, c’est genre « cet homme
obtient ce qu’il veut de moi ».
(Rires)
Ah mais je vous le dis direct !
Non, en vrai, ça m’a rassuré
parce qu’il me ressemblait.
On aurait dit moi mais version pro max.
(Rires)
On aurait dit moi :
renoi, tatoué, musclé, yeux verts.
(Rires)(Applaudissements)
Moi quand je rêve de moi,
le moi que j’aurais voulu être,
c’est-à-dire que : « Maman, moi,
c’est ça que je voulais à la base. »
Je dis ça parce que je ne sais pas
ce qu’elle nous a fait, la vieille encore,
mais ce n’est pas bon.
Attention, je l’aime, ma mère, je l’aime
de tout mon cœur - Maman, je t’aime -
mais là, non.
Là, il faut protester,
on voit bien que le projet fini,
ben justement, il n’est pas fini là...
Oui, il y a un problème
dans la réalisation.
L’impression 3D s’est mal passée.
Donc je m'adresse à l'homme de mes rêves.
« J’aimerais m’inscrire en salle de sport.
- Oui, je comprends. »
(Rires)
J'ai laissé passer.
Qu’est-ce que tu veux que je fasse ?
(Rires)
Non !
« Qu’est-ce tu veux ?
Tu veux gagner de la masse,
gagner de la force
ou gagner de l’endurance ?
- Mec, je veux tout.
(Rires)
Je veux gagner. D’accord ?
Je veux pour une fois gagner.
Les trois que tu as dit,
j’en n’ai aucun, mec.
Mets-moi la totale,
fais-moi cracher de la tune,
je veux avoir un corps.
Un corps digne de ce nom. D’accord ?
Je ne veux pas juste
le petit revêtement autour de l’os.
Je veux...
(Grognements)
Je veux ça. »
Le mec m’a dit : « Ok, on va
vous faire un programme sportif.
Mais pour ça, il me faut
ta taille, ton poids. »
Je lui donne ma taille :
1m80, c’est stylé.
Comment ?
(Rires)
Vous faites 1m80, madame ?
C'est stylé !
Tu fais 1m80,
c’est une belle taille pour un homme.
Tout le style du mètre 80,
tu le perds sur les 50 kilos que je pèse.
Ne rigolez pas,
je pèse réellement 50 kilos.
Mais voilà...
Ne vous inquiétez pas, j’ai cette réaction
quand je dis aux gens que je pèse 50 kg.
D’ailleurs...
Oui oui oui, je pèse réellement 50 kg.
La dame au premier rang,
elle a fait : « Hein ? Oh la la !
Il doit rester chez lui en cas de cyclone.
(Rires)
Un coup de vent d’ouest
et il se retrouve à Bélem, le frère. »
C’est un moyen peu coûteux de voyager,
mais un peu plus risqué.
(Rires)
C’est surtout l’atterrissage,
en fait, qui est dangereux.
Enfin, bref.
D’ailleurs, justement, j’ai vu
dans ses yeux à ce prof de sport,
Quand je lui ai dit que je pesais 50 kg,
j’ai vu dans ses yeux que...
non, il n’était plus là.
Non, je l'avais perdu, je l'avais perdu.
Je vais vous faire une confidence,
les amis.
J’ai beaucoup d’amies filles -
dû à mon manque évident de virilité.
(Rires)
Rigole, rigole.
Bravo ! Bravo !
Très malin.
Elles me parlent souvent
de l’insécurité qu’elles ressentent
à vivre dans un monde rempli d’hommes
qui représentent potentiellement
une menace.
Je sais... Pourquoi vous rigolez à ça ?
(Rires)
C’est le moment sérieux du sketch, là.
(Rit)
Ce n’est pas normalement
le moment où on rigole.
Mesdames, je sais à quel
point c’est dur pour vous.
Parce que vous ne pouvez pas
exister normalement.
Vous ne pouvez pas aller au magasin,
sortir dans la rue, aller en soirée,
sans vous sentir vulnérable.
Et les amis, cette vulnérabilité,
pendant un très court instant,
je l’ai ressentie.
Je l’ai ressentie,
parce que j’ai vu dans ses yeux,
quand j’ai dit mon poids, je me suis
senti comme une meuf en boîte de nuit
(Rires)
parce qu'il n'avait qu'une seule envie,
c'était de me soulever.
D’accord ?
(Rires)
Au sens littéral du terme !
Parce qu’il le peut.
Attention, parce que quand
je lui ai dit que je pesais 50 kg,
il a fait : « Ah oui ! »
Et il m’a dit, droit dans les yeux,
sans aucun souci,
cette phrase tellement humiliante :
« 50 kilos, c’est le poids que je fais
en développé couché pour m’échauffer. »
Pour t’échauffer.
C’est ça que je représente à tes yeux :
je suis un échauffement. Voilà !
Mesdames, messieurs,
ça veut dire deux choses, cette phrase.
Non seulement ce mec me soulève,
(Rit)
mais en plus, tranquille.
Il me soulève sans aucun souci.
D’accord ?
Je suis vulnérable quand je vais là-bas.
Je ne suis plus un être humain.
Quand je vais dans cette salle de sport,
je suis un haltère, d’accord ?
(Rires)
Je suis un échauffement.
En vrai, je m’énerve, mais j’en rigole
parce que j’ai appris que grandir,
c’est aussi prendre en sagesse.
Moi par exemple, je me sens mieux
dans mon corps et dans ma tête
et aussi je m’en fous
des injonctions à la virilité.
J'ai des cheveux, je pèse 50 kilos et je
fais ce que j'aime et c'est ça qui compte.
J’espère que je ne vous ai pas
trop ennuyés avec mes états d’âme.
En fait, je n’ai pas les moyens
de me payer un psy.
(Rires)
Du coup, ce soir, Madame,
c’est vous mon psy.
(Rires)
Merci beaucoup, c’était Clément Cerneaux.
(Applaudissements)